الى شنغن من اشهر الاسماء في العالم
وبالتحديد اسم اشهر تاشيره سفر في العالم
وهي تسمح بالتجول بين حدود دوليه 26 دون
تدقيق في الظروف العاديه اعتبارا من بدايه
العام الجاري سيتسع فضاء شنغن ليشمالك
كرواتيا العضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي وكذلك
بعد ان سوف اذكر
281 توصيه لكي تحقق شروط الفضاء شنقا هذه
الكلمه مرتبطه بالسفر واتفاقيه التي تفتح
حدود الدول الموقعه عليها عام 1995 لكنها
في الاساس اسم قريه صغيره تقع جنوب شرق
لوكسمبرج على حدود فرنسا اليوم صباح
العربيه سنتعرف عليها اكثر في شنغن بازاري
بعد قليل
لطال مرتبه اسم شيرين بتاشيرات السفر لكن
ما لا يعلمه الكثيرون انه الاسم يرجع
لقريه صغيره تقع اقصى جنوب الاقسام بريك
تحتضن القريه المتحف الاوروبي الذي يوثق
دورها في توحيد اوروبا من خلال الاتفاقيه
الشهيره التي ابرمت عام
تطل على الضفه الغربيه لنهار ميسي في
منطقه وادي موسى شديد الجمال حيث منحدرات
مزارع العنب موقعها الفريد الذي يربط عدد
الدول مثل الفرنسي ولوكسمبرج والمانيا هو
الذي خولها لتشهد توقيع واحده من اشهر
الاتفاقيات الاوروبيه
هذا رغم الصغر حجمها وقله عدد سكانها
الذين يبلغون حاليا ما يقرب من 1700 نسمه
فقط
ويتحدثون الالمانيه والفرنسيه
والاكسسبرغاريه واحيانا الهولنديه في
المقابل يزور القريه كل عام اكثر من
50,000 شخص من كافه انحاء العالم وليس
بعيدا عن قريه شنغن يوجد واحد من اكبر
المتاحف الحربيه في اوروبا المتحف الوطني
للتاريخ العسكري والذي يضم العديد من
مخلفات الحرب العالميه الثانيه الاصليه
[موسيقى]
اذا نذهب معكم الى شنغن واصل اصحابنا قائد
الرحله الصباح من صباح العربيه مراسلها
لايف بازار يسعد صباحك ليث ليث دائما لما
بنقول يعني اغلبنا بيخطر على بالنا هي
التاشيره او الفيزا وكثير قلال منه بيخطر
على بالهم فكره القريه وجودها القريه بس
انت دايما مميز بتقاريرك وبتاخذ زوايا
لافته مش ماخوذه دائما شو بدك تحكي لنا
اليوم
صباح الخير او صباحك جميله يا نادين من
منتجع الدوماندو لاكلوس في قريه مونتيناخ
مونتناخ بالالمانيا
مربى الكرز الاسود والتين البنفسجي من صنع
وعسل
هذا العسل طبعا عندنا جبنه الاجبان
لوز في هذه المنطقه وعندنا كمان لف السل
من مزرعه
اللي هي طبعا اشبان بتكون سائله شويه بين
لبن مشهوره
في فرنسا كمان من فرنسا والمانيا وهولندا
وبالجيكا هلا بنحكي اكثر تفاصيل وكذلك
عندنا اثبات طبعا
وهي طبعا من اشهر انواع الخبز والكيكس
كمان الموجوده في المنطقه في منطقه طبعا
سيخ التي تبعد من هنا ثلاثه
هي اهم الدول التي شكلت اوروبا اعاده طبعا
ايطاليا فهنا في منطقه شنغن بتشوف منطقه
المهزل تقع في فرنسا والمانيا موجوده برده
في المنطقه وبلجيكا وبلجيكا ولكسمبورغ
وهولندا وتسمى هذه المنطقه بقعه الحدود
وكذلك
لبيبيين يعني بلاد السبع تلال سياحيا
يقصدها سكان بلدان اوروبا لكثره الينابيع
والانهار
الموجوده بكثره في هذه المنطقه وخدره
حقولها الخلابه وشراء طبعا العصر الحكينا
عنه في هذه المنطقه الموجود وكذلك ما غال
او هي نوع من شبيه من البرقوق للاسف مش
موسم هلا بس جبنا طبعا
كونفتير منه موجود معنا فهاي المنطقه يعني
مشهوره بيزوها كثير همم ناس من من عده من
اغلب دول اوروبا لانه بتقدري مثل ما بنقول
بتصير اكثر من عصفور لانه هي المنطقه تجمع
بين كلها البلدان الموجوده الرجاءنا
للحديث نرجع للسؤالك الاول يا ندين عن
شنغن فهي طبعا قريه بسكان يعني ينقسمون
بين ثلاث بلدان المانيا وفرنسا ودسمبورج
ولهذا السبب يقصدها سكان فرنسا والمانيا
الى الشق اللوكسيمبر اذا سحبت تعبير من
هذه البلد او من هذه البلده يعني فمثلا
اذا احد حكينا عن ازمه الوقود الشهيره
التي ضربت فرنسا بعد اضرابات توتال شفنا
الكثير من الفرنسيين يذهبون لشراء الوقود
من هذه البلده لسبب لاسباب عده طبعا لانه
وفره هذه هذا الوقود ورقص اسعارها مقارنه
مع المانيا وسبب اخر لقصد الشقسمبورجي هو
انخفاض الضرائب منخفاض الضرائب مثل ما
بنعرف يعني اسعار ارخص وخصوصا راح احكي لك
كلمه نقدر نقول الطبخ بس مش مش لازم
نحكيها ابدا ولا الالكترونيات كثير من ناس
بيجوا على ليكسمبورج عفوا بيجوا على
الشنغن تحديدا بهذا السبب لاختلاطها او
لقربها من هذه البلدان واذا حكينا عن شنغن
في كثير ناس بغلطه في عنا مثلا ايسلندا
والنرويج وسويسرا هم دول مضوا جزءا من
معاهدات شنغن او من معاهده شنغن وليسوا
بالاتحاد الاوروبي واماره موناكو وسلم
مارينو
وبالفاتيكان الفاتيكان فتحوا همم حدودهم
بين دول اوروبا ولكن ليس اع- ليس اعطاء في
تاشيرات المنطقه الاوروبيه او فيزا فريزون
بس في بلدان ليسوا جزءا من القاره
الاوروبيه لكنهم اعضاء في معاهده شنجان
مثل اوزيراس وجزيره ماديرا البرتغاليه
وجزر الكناري وهناك دول تطمح للدخول في
الاتحاد الاوروبي ومعاهده شنغن بعد طبعا
كرواتيا الحكيم عنها قبل شويه
البانيا التي تكون في هذا البلد في كثير
اشياء بالحياه بنسمعها بس ما بنعرف شو
اصلها بنعرف انه شنغن تاشيره شنغن بس هي
هاي المدينه التي تم فيها تمت فيها هذه
المعاهده
الفطور الفاخر بشنغن وهاي انواع الاجبان
وايضا المربى والعسل الشهير في هذه
المنطقه شكرا
مراسل صباح العربيه ليتزالي يسعد صباحك